demonstrations are expected across
france today
in a show of solidarity after the
beheading of a teacher on his way home
from school
thousands gathered in central paris to
pay their respects
to samuel patty who was killed after
showing cartoons of the muslim prophet
muhammad
in a class on freedom of expression
people held aloft posters declaring
quote
no totalitarianism of thought police
have now detained 11 people in
connection with the killing
the suspect was shot dead by police soon
after the attack
shocked children parents and neighbors
come to pay their respects
at the suburban paris school where the
murdered teacher taught
although the school had received one
complaint after his classroom discussion
surrounding caricatures of islam's
prophet muhammad
the teacher didn't have a reputation for
being provocative
my oldest boy said he never behaved in a
racist way
not at all his lessons weren't intended
to shock
my son didn't think there was anything
unusual about him
france's education minister vowed the
country would never bow to terror
intimidation when it came to defending
its core principles
this teacher was murdered because of
what he symbolized
knowledge used for critical thinking
the development of citizens who are free
and enlightened it's the heart of what
we do in our schools
many in france support taking a tough
line against extremists
for a long time our secular country has
been under attack
but this time it's on education and it's
gone too far
it's the very values of the republic
that are being attacked here
we cannot allow that we need to bang our
fists on the table and say
enough
the government recently said it was
planning new measures to reign in
radicalism
advocates will see the latest attack as
proof that tougher action is needed
i'm joined now by anne elizabeth mutay a
journalist
in paris and elizabeth good to have you
with us
there are demonstrations and solidarity
rallies for the victim taking place
across the country
what more can you tell us about them
uh there are demonstrations in about uh
ten large cities in france and they
include paris
bordeaux
and there's an outrage in the country
that is comparable to the outrage when
the cartoonist of charlie abdul were
slain five years ago that
the teacher who's trying his best to
educate
children he was actually just killed by
terror
a terrorist is there any new information
about the attacker
we know quite a few things now we know
that he's an
18 year he was an 18 year old chechen
who uh
was born in moscow was refused asylum in
poland
was about to be refused asylum in france
but
that was overruled by a judge and
who apparently has been radicalized
in various ways we do not know what we
do not know is whether he was preparing
for this against this teacher it
could not have been a very long time
because the teacher had not been
targeted until
he made that course that lesson uh less
than a week ago
uh but we also know that uh
he was not a pupil in that school
he did not attend that the class he took
it upon himself
to go and kill the teacher as surely you
know
france's long-balanced secular and
christian
traditions and yet over the years
there's been a rise in
influx some would say of extremist
elements
outsiders might quickly attribute these
attacks to that inevitable tension
how did the french explain it
the french explain it exactly as you did
which is that
uh we have had for a long time
are muslims in france because france had
muslim colonies and then
uh after colonization uh they still came
to france
and the relationships uh with the the
first generation were pretty good and
they were not radicalized in a way that
we are now seeing
which dates back from the 1980s when
wahhabi islam
extremist islam funded at the time by
saudi arabia
and now still funded by qatar and others
started
demanding more and more separate ways of
living
uh for instance we have a bill against
the full covering the bulka
and that did not exist in algeria did
not exist in morocco et cetera but it
appeared in france
usually among converts and that was a
lot
many signs of people who wanted to live
a life completely apart
uh do not allow for instance that women
to go out etc and who
resent any uh expression of free speech
that doesn't
fit their narrow conceptions of religion
and elizabeth mute
in paris for us thank you so much and
elizabeth